kidnapping survivor Jamie Klaus will be
spared the trauma of testifying against
her captor
that's because Jake Patterson pleaded
guilty in Wisconsin yesterday to
abducting the thirteen-year-old teenager
last October and to murdering her
parents David beg no is here to show the
emotional day in court David good
morning Gail good morning Jake Patterson
told authorities he knew he wanted to
kidnap Jamie cloths after he saw her
getting off of a school bus right near
her house the fact that he pleaded
guilty means Jamie is not going to have
to testify in front of a jury and relive
the horror of what she went through Jake
Patterson walked into the courtroom with
a smile he appeared to acknowledge his
family and then sat out the plead guilty
guilty
Patterson admitted to kidnapping Jamie
Claus last October and holding her
captive he also admitted to killing her
parents James and Denise cloths his
attorneys say they gave Patterson
options for mounting a defense but he
rejected all of them mr. Patterson has
wanted to enter a plea from the day we
met him
Jamie Claus was not at the hearing her
family was but they left without
commenting for nearly three months
Jamie's disappearance United thousands
of people who were all trying to find
her finally it was this 911 answered her
family's prayers after kloss escaped the
attention turned to helping her
Elizabeth Smart who was kidnapped in
2002 and escaped nine months later spoke
to people in clausus hometown about how
they can help Jamie find a new normal
after Patterson's plea Elizabeth Smart
said in a statement I am grateful that
she and her family will be able to avoid
the challenges and distractions
surrounding the legal process and can
dedicate their time and attention to
continuing to heal just days after Jamie
was reunited with her family her on told
Gail king that the healing process was
going to be their sole focus right now
that first step is surrounding her by
law making sure she's safe she feel
say Patterson is scheduled to be
sentenced on May 24th he's likely going
to face life in prison Wisconsin does
not have the death penalty and by the
way viana when Patterson was walking out
of the courtroom he appeared to turn to
the gallery and say something we had a
producer in the courtroom who couldn't
make out what he said but the Star
Telegram is reporting he mouthed the
words by Jamie hopefully this can all
move quickly for Jamie's sake through a
recovery David thank you